ich war in malbek direkt neben dem Mann
der sich in die Luft gesprengt hat
ich habe keinerlei Erinnerung an den
Anschlag
[Musik]
ich muss hier raus denn wenn es eine
zweite Explosion gibt ist es vorbei ich
muss mich retten ich muss mein Baby
retten
[Musik]
wir hoffen vor allem dass dieser Prozess
sehr schnell zu Ende geht denn es extrem
belasten und bei uns kommen sehr
negative Dinge hoch wir durchleben
erneut eine ziemlich dunkle Zeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch sieben Jahren nach den
Terroranschlägen in Brüssel fährt Sabine
ungern mit der Bahn heute fällt es ihr
besonders schwer
[Musik]
ich will sagen können dass ich dabei war
aber ich weiß nicht ob ich noch mal
hingehe ich habe keine Ahnung in welchem
Zustand ich danach sein werde
wir begleiten Sie auf dem Weg zu ihrem
ersten Tag am Gericht
lange hatte sie gezweifelt ob sie
wirklich zum Prozess gehen will zum
Prozess gegen die mutmaßlichen
Attentäter von Brüssel
[Musik]
ohne eine vertraute würde sie diesen
Gang nicht wagen Jamila Ada begleitet
sie schon seit Jahren durch Höhen und
Tiefen
kommt heute mit frischen Narben zum
Prozess wie lief die OP das Auge ist
noch etwas angeschwollen hier sind noch
Fäden drin
über dem Auge waren noch Metallteile
unter der Haut Splitter der
Bombenexplosion heute wird sie sich so
den Angeklagten zeigen
[Musik]
schnell machen
ich hatte ein bisschen Angst davor aber
die Narben sind nun mal auch ein Teil
von mir Sabina sabine war lange Zeit auf
ihre Gesundheit fokussiert sie hatte
viele Operationen wie viele andere Opfer
auch
so gab es bisher wenig Raum sich mit den
Angeklagten oder dem Prozess zu
beschäftigen
geht jetzt gleich in den Gerichtssaal
und deutlich angespannt aber mit
Unterstützung du bist wunderbar
weiter dürfen wir Sie mit der Kamera
hier im Gericht nicht begleiten
ein mega-prozess das Medieninteresse
beim Prozess Auftakt im Dezember ist
riesig auch wir vom ZDF sind dabei
[Musik]
ein neues hochsicherheitsgericht wurde
eigens eingerichtet im ehemaligen
NATO-Hauptquartier
[Musik]
Geschworene und ersatzgeschworene wurden
ausgewählt es gibt rund 1.000
Nebenkläger
10 Angeklagte müssen sich für die
Terroranschläge in Brüssel verantworten
darunter Schlüsselfiguren wie Salah ab
des Lamm
Mohammed abrini
[Musik]
Osama kreyen
die Anklage gegen alle lautet
terroristischer Mord und versuchter
terroristischer Mord
sechs der zehn wurden bereits in Paris
verurteilt denn sie waren auch an den
Anschlägen dort beteiligt ein halbes
Jahr bevor sie in Belgien zu schlugen
[Musik]
auch deshalb musste Brüssel so lange auf
diesen Prozess warten jetzt darf nicht
schief gehen es geht ums aufarbeiten und
abschließen für ein ganzes Land
sabine hat ihren ersten Tag vor Gericht
geschafft wie ist es gelaufen
viele verschiedene Gefühle
aber eigentlich geht es mir ganz okay
ich habe ein bisschen das Gefühl einen
Film zu gucken
sie war von Anfang an super stark
neben dem Gerichtsgebäude will die
opferorganisation live vor Brussels zu
Prozessbeginn 1 klar machen es muss um
die Opfer gehen die Anwälte hier
vertreten hunderte Nebenkläger doch Jana
Metaller ist eines der wenigen Opfer die
sich der Presse stellen sie fühlt sich
stark genug
[Musik]
ich bin bei dem Anschlag in der Metro
verletzt worden als ich auf dem Weg zur
Arbeit war
eigentlich
ich war im 7 monat schwanger mit meinem
ersten Kind
ich hatte schwere Verbrennungen an den
Händen im Gesicht und an den Beinen den
Baby geht es gut sie ist heute
sechseinhalb Jahre alt
Profess
ionelle die Präsident
sehr positiv ist dies der Prozess der
Angeklagten aber viele Opfer wollen
aussagen wollen erklären was an diesem
Tag passiert ist erklären was sie erlebt
haben was sie gesehen haben das ist sehr
wichtig
auch die 50-Jährige Jana will ihre
Geschichte vor Gericht erzählen und sie
erklärt sich bereit sie auch uns zu
erzählen uns in den kommenden Wochen zu
berichten wie sie den Prozess erlebt
ich wusste immer dass ich zum Prozess
gehen muss wenn er endlich stattfindet
egal wie müde ich bin oder welche
anderen Probleme ich vielleicht gerade
habe jetzt muss ich schauen wie ich das
mit meinem Alltag vereinbaren kann ich
bin niemand der schwierigen Situationen
aus dem Weg geht
ich denke dass man sich dem stellen muss
damit man noch stärker wird
[Musik]
elbershiri ist auch Opfer der Anschläge
mit dem Prozess will er aber möglichst
wenig zu tun haben
[Musik]
er hat bereits seinen Weg gefunden um
weiterzumachen in einer Brüsseler Schule
will er seine Botschaft heute vermitteln
[Musik]
ich war schon immer ein zutiefst
humanistischer
ich bin Muslimen aber für mich war das
nie ein Hindernis um andere Menschen zu
treffen nach den Anschlägen ist es umso
wichtiger denn für mich ist es meine Art
die tödliche Ideologie des is zu
bekämpfen
und letztlich bekämpfe ich jede
Ideologie des Hasses
Ideologie
er ist auch ein Opfer der Anschläge mit
Migrationshintergrund wir müssen uns
alle bewusst machen dass es auch Muslime
gibt die betroffen sind
zusammen mit der Tochter einer Holocaust
Überlebenden auf Tilda Russo erzählt von
der Zeit ihrer Mutter in Auschwitz und
von ihrer eigenen Kindheit
[Musik]
jedes Kind braucht eine Mutter sie war
der wertvollste Mensch in meinem Leben
in einem Gedicht hat sie ihre
Erinnerungen festgehalten
um das Wort Mama auszusprechen küssen
sich die Lippen
ich brauche meine Mutter egal wie alt
ich bin
meine Mutter brachte mich zum Lachen
richte mir die Tränen weg
küsste mich
sie erzählt von den grolltaten der Nazis
unter denen ihre Mutter leiden musste
aber es ist vor allem das Gedicht über
ihre Mutter was Nachhalt als Mohammed
die Bühne betritt
[Applaus]
für mich ist es heute etwas schwierig
weil der Prozess um die Anschläge vom 22
März begonnen hat
das bedeutet dass viele Dinge wieder
hochkommen ich muss zugeben dass ich
ziemlich aufgewühlt bin
ich bin außerdem sehr gerührt denn in
ihrem Gedicht über ihre Mutter gab es
einige sehr schöne Passagen
bei mir zu Hause wird das Wort Mama
nicht mehr ausgesprochen in meine Kinder
sagen es nur manchmal noch um sich an
ihre Mutter zu erinnern
ihre Mutter die nicht mehr da ist
ihre Mutter Mohammeds Frau Lugner
gestorben bei den Anschlägen in Brüssel
der 22 März 2016 ein Dienstag
um 7:58 Uhr explodiert eine Bombe am
Brüsseler Flughafen zabenthem direkt
neben einem Check-in-Schalter
5000 Passagiere sind an diesem Morgen in
der Abflughalle wenig später explodiert
eine zweite Bombe gleich neben einer
Eingangstür
in der Metrostation mahlbeck explodiert
eine dritte Bombe rund eine Stunde
später um 9 Uhr elf
im Herzen des Brüsseler Europaviertels
Attentate des sogenannten islamischen
Staates
insgesamt sterben 32 Menschen mindestens
340 werden verletzt
ich bin Sabine ich war in der Metro mal
weg direkt neben dem Mann der sich in
die Luft gesprengt hat
ich habe keinerlei Erinnerung an den
Anschlag an die Intensivstation oder an
das was danach passiert ist
sechs Monate totale Lehre
ich bin Christian ich bin der Fahrer der
Metro ich habe versucht zu vergessen
aber das ist mir nie gelungen
ich habe mich immer geweigert darüber zu
sprechen auch zu Hause
am Tag nach dem Anschlägen bin ich
sofort wieder zur Arbeit gegangen denn
meine Frau war schwer krank und wir
mussten die Rechnungen bezahlen wenn ich
nicht sofort wieder angefangen hätte
hätte ich es nie getan
[Musik]
der Prozess läuft nun seit einigen
Wochen wir dürfen heute bei dieser
Gesprächsrunde dabei sein
Opfer wie Sabine bekommen hier während
des Verfahrens Hilfe von einer
Psychologin für Trauma Bewältigung
diese traumatisierenden geradezu
unaussprechlichen Ereignisse begleiten
Sie über viele viele Jahre hinweg und
verändern nicht nur ihr Leben sondern
oft auch ihre Sicht auf die Welt
für die meisten ist das Leben nach den
Anschlägen nie wieder so geworden wie
vorher das wird hier klar
ich werde oft gefragt was ich will das
ist nicht schwer ich will mein Leben
zurück das ist alles
dass die Anschläge auch nach so vielen
Jahren noch das Leben der Opfer
bestimmen können am besten die verstehen
die ähnliches erlebt haben das reicht
aber nicht
psychisch und in Bezug auf das was sie
erlebt haben fühlen sie sich allein
deshalb ist sehr wichtig dass der Staat
und das ganze Land hinter den Opfern
steht und ihnen sagt was euch passiert
ist ist auch uns passiert
beim Terrorismus geht es ja genau darum
über einzelne Menschen eine ganze
Gesellschaft zu treffen
[Musik]
ist Schweden lebt schon lange in Brüssel
sie will uns Ihr persönliches Wunder
zeigen ihre Tochter Miley
dass die beiden hier heute zusammen
spielen können ist nicht
selbstverständlich
es gibt einmal das was war und dann das
was ist da war dieses dramatische
Ereignis aber heute sind wir hier das
bedeutet alles für mich da kommen sofort
die Emotionen hoch
[Musik]
denn gleichzeitig sind da die Bilder vom
22 März 2016 die Bilder aus der Metro
ständig präsent jack & prito ich habe
sofort verstanden was gerade passiert
war denn ich wusste von dem Anschlag am
Flughafen also sagte ich mir ich muss
hier raus denn wenn es eine zweite
Explosion gibt ist es vorbei
ich muss mich retten ich muss mein Baby
retten ich habe nur an mein Baby gedacht
und gar nicht gemerkt wie schwer ich
selbst verletzt war
Jana schwere Verbrennungen verlor fast
ihre Hände musste vier Monate im
Krankenhaus bleiben Miley ihr
ungeborenes Baby überlebte all dies ohne
bleibende Schäden anders als Jana
ich habe noch immer viele
Schwierigkeiten je nach Phase ich bin
körperlich eingeschränkt
aler Ebene gibt es Höhen und Tiefen
es ist nicht die ganze Zeit da aber es
ist etwas das immer bei uns bleiben
sie sagt manchmal keine Sorge Mama wir
kaufen neue Hände für dich
das ist die Unschuld von Kindern sie hat
ein sehr gutes Herz
für mich bedeutet das sehr viel mehr als
Sie sich vorstellen kann
[Musik]
ein Platz mitten im Brüsseler Stadtteil
molenweg benannt nach Lugner Ehefrau von
Mohammed elbairi und Mutter von drei
Söhnen
[Applaus]
sie war eine außergewöhnliche Frau eine
liebenswerte Frau mit einem engelhaften
Lächeln mit einer großen Freundlichkeit
eine Frau die sich sehr um andere
kümmerte sie war eine tolle Mutter die
ihre Kinder liebte eine Frau voller
Energie und Lebensfreude
Mohammed erzählt uns gerne von Lugner
aber nicht von dem Tag vor sieben Jahren
an dem sie in der Metro starb
bist
der größte Albtraum es war chaotisch ich
möchte lieber nicht zu viel darüber
sprechen das holt sonst schreckliche
Dinge hervor
wir kommen manchmal hierher um eine
Verbindung zu Lugner zu suchen
wenn wir über sie sprechen egal wo
sie durch die Erinnerungen wieder
lebendig
[Musik]
der 42-Jährige lebt mit seinem jüngsten
Sohn Sahin sowie zwei weiteren Söhnen in
molenweg vor den Anschlägen war er
metro-fahrer er hat seinen Beruf
aufgegeben und versucht nun den Alltag
als alleinerziehender Vater zu
bewältigen
ich kümmere mich um meine Kinder und
sorge dafür dass sie gut ausgebildet
sind gute Bürger werden
dass Sie Träume haben Ambitionen und
Pläne für ihr Leben das ist es was
wichtig ist
sehr gut
du bist doch noch mein kleiner
[Musik]
ich muss mit den Händen arbeiten ich bin
keine intellektuelle
s Alltag ist noch heute von den Folgen
der Anschläge geprägt ihre Hände ermüden
schnell verkrampfen sich häufig
da meine Hand verbrannt war konnte ich
sie lange nicht benutzen ich wusste
nicht mehr wie man die Finger öffnet und
beugt ich musste das alles neu lernen
mehr als 40 Operationen hat sie bereits
hinter sich ihren Beruf als
Schmuckdesignerin kann sie nicht mehr
ausüben
am Anfang war ich wütend
weil ich das schon immer gemacht hatte
ich kannte nichts anderes und ich liebte
es Schmuck herzustellen ich liebte es
mit verschiedenen Materialien zu
arbeiten und etwas daraus zu machen
aber aus der Wut wurde eine Frage okay
was jetzt
[Musik]
kann ich etwas anderes machen
nachdem sie in den letzten Jahren sehr
viel Zeit in Krankenhäusern und bei
Ärzten verbracht hat nutzt Sabine nun
jede Gelegenheit für andere Aktivitäten
[Musik]
in einem Malkurs verarbeitet sie das was
sie erlebt hat
eine
Explosion denn die ist real für mich und
in der Mitte werden Wörter stehen Wörter
wie Dschihadist Angst Wut Bombe
Erinnerung
sie hat einen Entwicklungsprozess
durchgemacht sicher auch innerlich
sie öffnet sich jetzt viel mehr der Welt
während sie anfangs sehr sehr
verschlossen war
jetzt diskutiert sie lacht amüsiert sich
und bringt die Leute zum lachen was
könnte besser sein es ist wunderschön
diese äußere und innere Heilung der
Mutter eines Sohnes dauert nun schon
sieben Jahre
als ich aus dem Krankenhaus entlassen
wurde war mein Sohn fünf sechs Jahre alt
er konnte die Treppe hinaufgehen ich
nicht ich konnte sprechen ich nicht
es war als ob ich erst ein Baby dann ein
Kind dann ein Teenager wurde und dann
erwachsen
eine alte Frau bin ich jetzt aber noch
nicht
[Musik]
und dann ist es ausgerechnet der Prozess
der bei vielen die Heilung zum Stocken
bringt denn der läuft nicht so wie die
Opfer wie ganz Belgien gehofft hatten
das ganze Land ist genervt von der
eigenen Justiz
[Musik]
bereits dafür oktober geplante Auftakt
hatte sich um zwei Monate verzögert
mehrere Angeklagte hatten sich geweigert
im Gerichtssaal in einzelnen
unterteilten panzerglaszellen zu sitzen
die Trennwände zwischen den Männern
wurden abmontiert die Angeklagten können
nun untereinander und mit ihren Anwälten
kommunizieren
[Musik]
im Dezember geht es dann endlich los
doch es ruckelt weiter die Angeklagten
beschweren sich über ihre
Transportbedingungen über tägliche
Leibesvisitation einige erscheinen nicht
mehr im Gerichtssaal es entbrennt ein
juristisches hin und her
sie müssen sich hinknien es gibt
Reizentzug Kameras über den Toiletten
also alles was es nicht geben dürfte
Bedingungen sind uns natürlich nicht
egal aber das darf auch nicht ins andere
Extrem und in Erpressung münden dass sie
jedes mal sagen wenn ihnen etwas nicht
passt dann sagen wir eben nicht aus
die Richterin erklärt dass sie nicht
zuständig ist also schreiben mit dem
Minister aber wir kriegen keine
zufriedenstellende Antwort
verhalten sie sich verantwortungsbewusst
nehmen Sie sich zurück und auch wenn es
schwer fällt kommen Sie zum Gericht
ziemlich schnell geht es nur noch um
eins die Befindlichkeiten der
Angeklagten das was die Opfer zu sagen
haben rückt im Gerichtssaal in den
Hintergrund
auch Jana metala nimmt dieser Prozess
mehr mit als erwartet einige Wochen lang
hatte sie uns nicht mehr treffen wollen
heute dürfen wir Sie zum Bahnhof
begleiten
[Musik]
in Bezug auf die Presse musste ich
Abstand gewinnen um mich darauf zu
konzentrieren was mit mir passiert wenn
ich zum Gericht gehe es ist
psychologisch schwierig emotional
schwierig es gibt sehr viele Dinge die
gerade schwierig sind und trotz allem
beharre ich auf der Idee dass ich den
Prozess weiter verfolgen möchte
auch deshalb bringt sie ihre Frau Maria
ihre Tochter Miley und ihren Sohn
Matthias heute zum Zug
ich reise nicht mit aber meine Frau mit
den beiden Kindern ist es möglich dass
wir die Platzreservierungen tauschen
die drei fahren zur Familie nach London
denn Jana braucht Zeit für sich ihre
Gedanken und den Prozess hallo
er kann den Platz leider nicht tauschen
du sollst direkt mit dem Zugchef
sprechen
es ist im Moment sehr schwierig für uns
als Familie
weil wir jeden Tag sehen wie Jana
gestresst nach Hause kommt
[Musik]
wir müssen versuchen das alles zu
überwinden
aber es gibt immer Konflikte und wir
müssen verstehen dass sie gestresst ist
aber wir sind es auch weil wir sie nicht
so viel sehen
das Schlimmste verdient das
allerschlimmste weil sie Familien
zerstört haben nur weil Jana noch lebt
heißt das nicht dass ihr uns nicht
zerstört haben denn wir waren vorher
nicht so wir hatten ein normales Leben
und danach war alles kaputt
die Hoffnung auf die heilende Wirkung
des Prozesses war groß doch jetzt reist
er erst einmal alle Wunden wieder auf
ich habe immer gemischte Gefühle und bin
gestresst wenn sie auf Reisen gehen das
immer die Angst dass etwas passieren
könnte
aber ich freue mich auch für Sie
ich weiß dass sie einen schönen Urlaub
haben werden
[Musik]
für Sabine bourgignon hingegen läuft der
Prozess besser als erwartet seit ihrem
ersten Tag im Gericht vor einigen Wochen
verbringt sie viel Zeit hier egal wie es
drinnen läuft von ihrer Angst zu Beginn
ist kaum noch etwas zu spüren allerdings
ist er jetzt eine neue Sorge
tatsächlich macht mir das Ende ein
bisschen Angst weil der Prozess jetzt
den gesamten Raum einnimmt ja ich bin
auch erleichtert wenn er zu Ende geht
aber gleichzeitig ist da auch die Angst
und die Frage was kommt danach
doch im Moment ist sie voll eingetaucht
in diesen Prozess bei Mittagessen in der
gerichtskantine hat sie heute eine
ungewöhnliche Verabredung
warum wisst ihr nicht wo sie begraben
sind
weil sie bei Bombenangriffen oder durch
Hinrichtungen getötet wurden und in
Massengräbern liegen daher wissen wir
nicht wo sie sind es gab keine
Beerdigung
die Frauen hier sprechen von ihren
Söhnen gestorben in Syrien als Kämpfer
des iss
einen Tag nach seinem 18 Geburtstag ist
er nach Syrien gegangen
es war der Tag an dem ich meiner Familie
sagte mein Sohn ist in den Tod gegangen
nach zwei Jahren der Trauer habe ich
endlich beschlossen etwas zu tun damit
das was mir passiert ist nicht auch
anderen passiert
zusammen mit anderen Müttern von
is-kämpfern unterstützt sie die
Terroropfer während des Prozesses neben
ihrer Präventionsarbeit doch die
Angeklagten zu sehen aber auch für sie
nicht leicht
beim ersten Mal habe ich geweint
aber ich habe um die Opfer geweint weil
es mir weh getan hat
auch wenn es nicht mein Sohn war der die
Anschläge verübt hat
tat es weh ich habe an ihn gedacht
ich bin für die Opfer hier ihnen
gegenüber habe ich mich sehr schuldig
und beschämt gefühlt und gedacht warum
man hätte schon vor langer Zeit etwas
dagegen tun sollen muss es immer erst
Opfer geben bevor wir etwas tun wir
müssen vorher handeln
wir sitzen alle im gleichen Boot
wir alle wurden auf die eine oder andere
Weise überrascht von dem was passiert
ist
davon zu erholen
[Musik]
molenbek viele der jungen Männer die
nach Syrien gingen kamen aus diesem
Brüsseler Stadtteil hier lebten auch
einige der Attentäter hier planten sie
die Anschläge von Paris und Brüssel und
hier lebt Mohammed elbairy
[Musik]
das ist zum Gedenken an die Opfer von
Paris und Brüssel
auch ihn treffen wir erst nach längerer
Zeit wieder auch ihnen nimmt der Prozess
mehr mit als erwartet das ganze von sich
fernhalten klappt nicht
gesagt ist das gerade eine ziemlich
schwierige Zeit ich musste mehrere
Treffen mit ihnen absagen weil es mir
wirklich nicht gut ging und ich nicht
bereit war zu reden
es gibt Hoch und Tief Phasen aber ich
bewundere meine Kinder sehr sie sind
wirklich meine Helden ihre
Widerstandsfähigkeit zu sehen meine
Kinder trotz allem zu sehen wie sie
leben Lächeln spielen
das ist ein Geschenk
sehr sehr
obwohl er eine schwere Zeit durchmacht
will er uns seinen molenweg zeigen das
freundliche und liebenswerte molenweg
nicht dass der Attentäter
Stigmatisierung etwas entgegenzusetzen
alle Augen waren nach den Anschlägen auf
uns gerichtet nur weil zwei drei
Fanatiker das unwiederbringliche getan
hatten sie repräsentieren aber absolut
nicht die 100.000 Einwohner von Polen
Weg
er nimmt uns mit in einen Tee Salon für
Mohammed war ist die Gemeinschaft hier
im Viertel die ihn in seinen dunkelsten
Stunden aufgefangen hat
die muslimische Gemeinschaft ist sehr
solidarisch sie beruht sehr stark auf
Empathie gegenseitiger Hilfe und
Brüderlichkeit
man ist füreinander da wenn es jemandem
schlecht geht
und das ist etwas sehr sehr schönes
auch das ist Brüssel auch das ist
molenweg
vor sieben Jahren nur zwei Monate nach
den Anschlägen als Mohammed das Haus
kaum noch verließ bekam er einen
rettenden Anruf
wir wurden während des Ramadan in die
Kirche eingeladen um gemeinsam zu essen
es war eine wirklich gute Zeit der
Gemeinschaft mit 500 Menschen
dort in der Kirche hielt er eine Rede
mit dem Titel die hat der liebe
daraus wurde seine Mission und ein Buch
das ist meine Art den Extremisten zu
Antworten die uns Spalten wollen indem
sie sagen dass die Christen und die
Juden Feinde sind ich sage nein
mohammed war mit einem der Attentäter in
der Grundschule darüber reden will er
nicht aber aus seiner Trauer wurde kein
Hass sondern eine Botschaft seine
Botschaft für uns alle
[Musik]
Brüderlichkeit wir sind alle Brüder sage
ich ist jemand der so etwas tut auch ein
Bruder ja das ist auch ein Bruder aber
ein Bruder der einen falschen Weg
gewählt hat als Mensch bleibt er dein
Bruder auch wenn er das allerschlimmste
getan hat
bitte wenn sie da kommen
[Musik]
lass uns mal gucken ich bin neugierig
Jana metala nimmt uns mit zu einem
Treffen auf dass sie sich sehr freut mit
der Fotografin nafissa yahouba die zeigt
ihr heute Bilder die sie von Janas
Familie gemacht hat für eine Ausstellung
über die Terroropfer
das da mag ich auch gerne
das ist niedlich sie tut ganz schüchtern
[Musik]
die Fotos sind wunderschön
es war wirklich ein schöner Moment den
wir mit der ganzen Familie verbracht
haben
ich konnte alle davon überzeugen
mitzukommen ich hatte das Gefühl dass es
etwas ist dass die andere schönere und
positivere Seite darstellt
einige der Bilder werden ausgestellt
zusammen mit Fotos von 29 weiteren
Terroropfern jedes Foto jede Geschichte
ist anders aber dahinter steht auch eine
kollektive Geschichte die ganz Brüssel
etwas angeht
wir haben die Menschen vergessen denen
das passiert ist das Problem ist auch
wie die Medien über sie berichten meist
sehr punktuell und dann ist es wieder
vorbei dabei geht es oft gar nicht um
die Menschen dahinter ich wünsche mir
dass wir uns gemeinsam die Zeit nehmen
darüber nachzudenken
und es geht darum dem Schicksal eine
positive selbstbestimmte Zukunft
entgegenzusetzen
die Idee war Fotos zu nutzen um das
auszudrücken was die Menschen die
direkten und indirekten Opfer der
Attentate empfinden oder teilen möchten
ich denke dass man in den Fotos eine
gewisse Stärke erkennen kann auch wenn
die Stärke oft schwangt
manchmal muss man suchen um sie zu
finden wenn es schwierige Momente gibt
aber sie ist trotz allem da
und ich denke man kann sie hier sehen
und nicht nur bei mir sondern auch meine
Tochter sieht sehr stark aus
[Musik]
sucht sich ihren Begleiter für heute aus
ihre Wahl fällt auf Satin um euch besser
kennenzulernen geht ihr einfach ein
bisschen spazieren
Reittherapie der Prozess motiviert
Sabine sich gerade jetzt ganz aktiv mit
sich selbst zu beschäftigen das Ziel
heute aufs Pferd steigen trotz
körperlicher Einschränkungen
[Musik]
das macht mir etwas Angst aber er
scheint ja einverstanden zu sein
[Musik]
Patrick Kimo erklärt Sabine wie sie mit
Saturn kommunizieren kann
das ist wie beim Tanzen
was der 48-Jährigen auch im Alltag hilft
sich ganz bewusst neuen
Herausforderungen zu stellen
[Musik]
und wie fühlst du dich
mit entspannen und anspannen soll Sabin
das Pferd steuern auch sieben Jahre nach
den Anschlägen hat sie noch immer nicht
die volle Kraft in den Beinen aber es
klappt
[Musik]
das ist ein sehr angenehmes Gefühl und
ja es macht mich auch stolz denn nachdem
ich drei Monate im Krankenhaus lag haben
sie meinen Eltern gesagt dass ich
vielleicht nie mehr sprechen nie mehr
laufen und eigentlich nur noch vor mich
hin vegetieren würde
so ist es nicht gekommen das ist enorm
Patrick arbeitet auch mit anderen
Terroropfern eine Sehnsucht kann er bei
ihnen allen feststellen
ich höre die Lust heraus mit etwas
Lebendigem zusammen zu sein und außerdem
ist es einfach Lebensfreude sie merken
ich kann Spaß haben
[Musik]
Brüssel die Stadt die noch heute Narben
trägt vom Terror vor sieben Jahren
ich war im siebten Monat schwanger und
heute ist das Baby sechseinhalb Jahre
alt
Bruno sie ist hier wir sind der Beweis
dafür dass das Leben an diesem Tag auch
gegen den Tod gewonnen hat
die Stadt in der vielleicht noch vor
Ende des Jahres ein lang ersehntes
Urteil fallen wird gegen die die dafür
verantwortlich sind
die U-Bahn in die Luft gejagt und ich
habe das nicht entschieden aber jetzt
kann ich über mein Leben entscheiden
deshalb gehe ich zum Prozess deshalb
male ich deshalb bin ich hier
die Stadt in der die Erinnerung
weiterlebt und wir beeindruckende
Menschen treffen durften die trotz allem
weitermachen mit Kraft und Leidenschaft
[Musik]
ich unsere Geschichte das wird vergehen
das Wesentliche für mich ist eine
Botschaft der Liebe und des Friedens zu
vermitteln denn das ist das was bleiben
wird
[Musik]